foreign
[Applause]
against it because there's too much
traffic
on in that area already here he is
saying that there's going to
disconnect the street well there are
Dark Skies
got bald eagle
why are you destroying an existing one
to create one just down the street
with with any kind of development like
that you have to go through the
permitting process and the county is not
very strong on how they do the
permitting personally it is my wish that
it does not get approved by Bastrop and
that he does not get his own town in our
County
to introduce a town that is controlled
and centralized around a company and
them controlling all of the families
that live there and having to produce
something as a product for him that's
that sounds scary like old mining towns
and we know company towns didn't work I
know that we need more affordable
housing I have an adult child who is
struggling to find affordable housing in
this County so I know that that is an
issue however it's really sketchy to me
that we're turning the clocks back and
doing like coal miner Town situation I
hope that the people who live in those
houses and in that Community do not get
stuck in the Trap of the things that you
saw in those types of you know planned
communities for business where you can't
buy anything and with with your money
except for the store or maybe it's just
more convenient for you to go there and
kind of make an insular community that
basically they become your indentured
servants because they have no way to
have the mobility out of it one
like say you lose you lose your job
mutt to get
to get out of that house
that's terrifying we've seen this in
history before we've seen it all over
the world including the United States we
know how this story ends so I'm not
saying that's what's gonna happen
because I'm not a mind reader I'm not a
fortune teller but I will say that all
the signs and symptoms of some
bull crap going down
are afoot
how will your
your residence living in your Utopia
feel about living next to a 2 000 acre
gravel mine
do they really want to live near a great
big hole do they do they want to have
polluted water do they want to have dust
in the air Utopia sounds very scary like
if you watch the Star Trek and such yeah
not good or read the books yeah the
Utopia is not usually at all what it's
presented to be